Let's go next to our caller from the three
zero one area code.
There is something a little funky going on
with the call system today, but we're going
to do our best to sort of work within what
is available to us.
So who's calling from three Oh one today.
Hey David, this is Jason.
I'm from Hagerstown, Maryland.
Hey Jason, what's going on?
Oh yeah, my question is about fake news and
what we can do to combat it and if the government
should, um, have any role in that.
Um, so, um, I'm becoming increasingly concerned
about, um, fake news and these conspiracy
movements.
Um, so just like anti vacs movements and um,
you know, like Fox news is defending Trump
at all costs and they're not grounded in reality.
Um, and things like climate change, they just
deny it when all scientists pretty much say
it's real.
Um, so I'm wondering what you think, um, we
can do to combat it and if the government
should have any, have any role in combat.
Okay.
So the, the, the problem is that when you
get to the point of arguing about or thinking
about whether the government should have any
role, it's sort of already too late.
Like if, if we have a society where we need
the government to combat fake news, we've
already sort of lost, and this goes back to
what I've been talking about, I talked about
it earlier this week.
We have an almost total lack of uh, schools
teaching people to really think for themselves
to understand epistemology, to understand
critical thinking.
And if an, until we have that, the government
combating fake news by putting restrictions
on Facebook or whatever the case may be, it's
too late in the process.
We need to be attacking this far, far earlier.
Now, if someone has a particular proposal
as to something that could be done by law
to try to quote, fight fake news, I'm not
opposed to it reflexively like on principle,
I'm open to listening to it.
But the problem is that if we had more adults
who just understand media literacy, understand
epistemology, understand arguments, understand
how to determine for themselves whether a
conclusion that is being sped to us actually
follows from the premises.
And whether the premises are precise and accurate,
we wouldn't be having the conversation about
this government need to need to deal with
this.
That's not the reality.
Government is in the picture because things
have gotten so bad, but it needs to really
be dealt with systemically starting far earlier
than when we would just say government needs
to fix it.
[inaudible]
right.
Yeah, I agree with that.
Um, I almost think it's too late at this point.
Uh, I mean there's just like so many people
that are just like a little college.
Yeah.
I mean it's never too late to start educating
people, but at this point a lot of people
lack the skills to really figure it out a
for for themselves, unfortunately.
[inaudible]
exactly.
All right, well thank you.